the leadership candidates came to stoke
on trent and they brought with them the
rain
in this traditionally labor voting
midland city that voted conservative for
the first time in 2019
what wasn't there to greet them was much
enthusiasm they're all self-serving
aren't they they don't do anything for
small towns in the north otherwise you
know where's the powerhouse of the north
that they promised us eight years ago
there's nothing here anymore it's dying
i don't know everyone makes mistakes but
i feel like when you run a country you
shouldn't make a mistake so everyone
just wants someone who's not gonna make
the country fail or like fail people
like boris johnson did foreign secretary
liz truss and former chancellor rishi
sunak face a summer leadership campaign
that kicked off in earnest with monday
night's debate
i have not taken the easy road right in
saying the things that i'm saying about
the challenges facing our economy and
what it's going to require to fix them
yeah that doesn't make my life any
easier i'm doing it because i want to be
honest with all of you i'm
straightforward i'm honest i'm straight
talking i might not be the slickest
presenter in the business but i do what
i say will do okay i've done it in trade
i've done it in the foreign office and i
will do it as prime minister restoring
trust unsurprisingly was a defining
issue there were areas of agreement on
the environment and foreign policy
towards china and russia the deepest
differences though were over the economy
disagreements on whether to lower taxes
or control inflation your proposals
would mean that we get the short-term
sugar rush of unfunded borrowed tax cuts
but that would be followed by the crash
of higher prices and higher mortgage
rates and that is not something that i
want to create the highest tax rate for
70 years and that is why rishi sunak was
seen as an unconservative chancellor why
a poll of conservative members who will
decide this race put liz trust 24 points
ahead sunak can only hope that he's done
enough to begin to change minds
they were pledges to fulfill boris
johnson's election promised to level up
long neglected areas in the midlands and
the north like stoke on trent over
successive decades here they've seen the
decline of their steel industry then
coal and ceramics
so you don't expect a sort of rousing
welcome here in stoke for these two
candidates trying to sell themselves to
the electorate i'd be surprised if the
uh left the city with the tyre is still
on the cars to be honest
[Laughter]
in five weeks time the promises made by
one of these candidates will be put to
the test jonah al jazeera stoke on trent